[Applaudissements]
benoît va lui il peut venir près de moi
bienvenue à ça tu vas faire nikos aussi
un [ __ ] alors la cgt celle s'est pas
non non non il veut tout contrôler oui
j'avais pas vu eux
alors comment on fermait petit beauté
démocratie c'est qu'ils sachent et pas
faire attention pour les téléspectateurs
alors je vais refaire la même chose qu'à
nerf à des élèves le château
mes personnages nabil m que jamais
regardé bon il aime que je dise que ces
quatre mots la lui peut pas dire johnny
louf annoncé jonny malbon faso voice
dakhla guan les élèves le château c'est
l'aveu château les élèves se lèvent au
château au cdh jamais maman merci
batista vous